the natural question when people hear
breakthrough with the with the inertial
confinement with the magnetic
confinement is so when will we have
commercial yeah
um reactors power plants that are
actually producing electricity what's
your sense um
looking out into the future when do you
think you can Envision the future where
we have actual electricity coming from
nuclear fusion partly driven by us but
in other places as well too so there's
the Advent what's you know what's so
different now than three or four years
ago like we launched around four years
ago what's so different now is is the
Advent of a very nascent but seemingly
robust like commercial Fusion you know
Endeavor so it's not just Commonwealth
Fusion systems there's something like 20
plus you know companies there's a sector
now there's a sector they actually they
actually have something called the
fusion industry Association which if
your viewers want to go see this this
describes the difference and they've got
this plethora of approaches like I
haven't even described all the
approaches I've basically described the
mainline approaches
um you know and they're all at varying
degrees of Technical and scientific
maturity with very huge different you
know balances between them but what they
share
is that because they're going out and
finding getting funding from the private
sector is that their stated goals are
about getting fusion into place so that
both it meets the investors demands
which are interesting right in the time
skills of that but also it's like well
there's gonna and why it's because it's
easy there's gonna there's this enormous
push
driver about getting carbon free energy
sources out into the market and whoever
figures those out is going to be both
very it's going to be very important
geopolitically but also economically as
well too so it's a different kind of
a bat I guess or a different kind of
gamble that you're taking with Fusion
but it's so disruptive that it's like
there's there's a essentially a class of
investors and teams that are ready to go
after it as well too so what do they
share in this they typically share
um getting after Fusion on a time scale
so that could it have any relevance
towards climate change baling climate
change and I would say this is difficult
but it's it's fairly easy because it's
math so what you do is you actually go
to some Target like 2050 or 2060
something like this and say I want to be
blank percent of the the world's market
of electricity or something like that
and you and we know historically what it
takes to evolve and distribute these
kinds of Technologies because every
technology takes some period of time
it's so-called s-curve it's basically
everything follows a logarithmic
exponential type curve it's a straight
line a log plot and like you look at
winds solar fission they all follow the
same thing so it's easy you take that
curve and you go that's slope and you
work backwards and you go if you don't
start in the early 2030s like
it's not going to have uh you know it's
not going to have a significant impact
by that time so all of them share this
idea and in fact it's not just the
companies now the U.S federal government
has a program that was started last year
that said we should be looking to try to
get like the first and what I mean by
like what does it mean to start that
you've got something that's putting
electricity on the grid a pilot what we
call it
and if that can get started like in the
early 2030s you know the idea of ramping
it up you know makes sense that's math
right so that's the ambition then the
question is and and actually this is
different because the government program
and that they vary around in this so for
for example the United Kingdom's
government idea was to get the first one
on by 2040. and China has Ambitions
probably middle 2030s uh or maybe a
little bit later and Europe uh you know
Continental Europe is it's a little bit
I'm not exactly sure where it is but
it's like later it's like 2050 or 2060
because it's mostly linked to the eater
timeline as well too
um the fusion companies which makes
sense it's like of course they've got
the most aggressive timelines it's like
we're going to map the human genome
faster as well too right so it's
interesting about where we are and I
think you know my we're not all the way
there but my intuition tells me we're
probably going to have a couple of
cracks at it actually uh on that
timeline so this is where we have to be
careful though you say commercial Fusion
you know what does that mean commercial
Fusion to me means that you actually
have a known quantity about what it
costs what it costs to build and what it
costs to operate the reliability of
putting energy on the grid that's
commercial Fusion it's like so it turns
out that that's not not necessarily
exactly the first Fusion devices that
put electricity on the grid because you
got it there's a learning curve to get
like better and better at it but that's
probably I would suspect the biggest
hurdle is to get to the first one the
work I've done uh the work I continue to
do with autonomous vehicles and
semi-autonomous vehicles there's an
interesting parallel there where a bunch
of companies announced a deadline for
themselves in 2020 21 22 and only a
small subset of those companies have
actually really pushed that forward this
Google with waymo or alphabet rather uh
is do and and then there's uh
uh Tesla with semia Thomas driving in
their autopilot full self driving mode
and those are different approaches so
Tesla is achieving much much higher
scale but the sort of the quality of the
drive is semi-autonomous right I I don't
know if there's a metaphor or an analogy
here and then there's waymo that's
focusing on very specific cities but
achieving real full autonomy with actual
passengers but the scale is much smaller
so I wonder like just like you said
there would be these kinds of similar
kind of really hard pushes absolutely so
actually this is what I it's why I'm
encouraged about Fusion now so Fusion is
still hard let's let everyone be clear
because of the signs under underneath it
of us of achieving the right conditions
for the plasma basically is a is a is a
yardstick that you have to put up
against all of them what's encouraging
that I see in this and it's actually
what happens when you sort of let loose
the creativity of this is maybe I'll go
back to First principles so Fusion is a
also a fairly strange so if you think
about building a coal Point like burning
wood and coal and gas is actually not
that much different from each other
because they're kind of about the same
physical conditions and you get the fuel
and you lighten it out Fusion is very
remember I told you that there's this
condition of the temperature which is
kind of universal
but if you take the density of the fuel
between magnetic fusion and inertial
fusion they're different by about a
factor of 10 billion so this and the
density fuel really matters that
actually so does the this means energy
confinement time is also different by a
factor of 10 billion as well too because
it's the product of those two so one's
really dense and short lived and the
other ones really long-lived and and
actually under dense as well too
so what that means is that the way to to
the the way to the to get the underlying
physical state is so different among
these different approaches what it lends
itself to is does this mean that
eventual commercial products will
actually fill different needs in the
energy system so it sort of goes to your
comment about
to suspect this it's because anything
that is high tech and is like a really
important thing in our economy tends to
never find its way as one only one
manifestation like look at
Transportation as well too we have
scooters
Vespas you know uh Overland trucks cars
electric cars of course we have these
because they meet different demands in
it so what's interesting you know that I
find fascinating now is that we have
infusion it's going to look like that
that probably there's the while the
near-term focuses on electricity
production there might even be different
kinds of markets that actually make
sense in some places less than others it
comes to trade-offs because we haven't
really talked about the engineering yet
but the engineering really matters like
to the to the operation of the device
and so it could be
um that that you know I suspect what
we'll end up with is several different
configurations which have different
features which are trade-offs basically
in in the energy Market what do you see
as the major engineering
or general hurdles yeah that are in the
way yeah
um so the first one is just the cost of
building a single unit
so Fusion has and is actually
interesting you talked about the about
the different models that you have so
Fusion has
um one of its interesting limitations is
that it's very hard
almost at some point becomes physically
impossible to actually make small power
units
like a kilowatt a thousand Watts you
know which is like a personal home like
you know this is about a thousand
dollars or your personal use of an
energy of electricities but like a
thousand Watts
um this is basically impossible and if
for a single you know unit to do this
um so like you're not gonna have a
fusion like power plant like is your
furnace in or your electric heater in
your home and the reason for this comes
from the fact that Fusion relies on it
being it's not just that it's very hot
it says that the fusion power is the
heating source to keep it hot so if if
you if you get if you go too small it
basically just cannot keep it hot that's
um so it's interesting is that this so
this is one of the hard parts so this
means that the individual units you know
and it's it varies from concept to
concept but the the national academies
report that came out last year sort of
put the Benchmark as being like probably
the minimum size looks like around 50
million watts of electricity which is
like another for like a meat like a
small to you know mid-sized City
actually
um so that is so that's sort of like a
scale Challenge and in fact it's one of
the reasons why in Commonwealth and
another private sector ones like we they
try to push this down actually of trying
to get to the to these smaller units
just because it reduces the cost of it
um then probably
um obviously it should obviously it's an
obvious one like achieving the fusion
State itself and High Gain Is is a hard
one what we already talked about what
kind of harder what kind of challenges
that that's achieving the right
temperature density and energy
confinement time in the fuel itself in
the plasma itself and so some of the so
some of the the configurations which are
being chosen have are actually uh have
quite a ways to go in fact I've seen
those but what their their consideration
is oh yes but by our particular
configuration the engineering Simplicity
confers like an economic Advantage even
if we're behind in sort of an assigned
sense okay which is fine this is also
what you get when you get a an explosion
in in the private sector you basically
are Distributing risks in different ways
right which makes sense
um all of that good that so what I would
say is that the the next hurdle to
really overcome is is about making that
electricity so like we need to see a
unit or several units like put using
Fusion in some way to put a meaningful
amount of energy on the grid because
this starts giving us real answers
um as to like what this is going to look
like the full end to end the full end to
end thing so Commonwealth's goal is that
I'll I'll just comment to Commonwealth
because I'll take some you know some I
get some credit for this is that the the
origins of Commonwealth were in fact in
examining that like we could see this
new technology coming forward this this
new superconducting material and the
origins of our thought process were
really around designing effectively the
pilot plant or the commercial unit it's
called Arc which is actually the step
forward after spark and that was the
orig the origins of it so all the things
that were other parts of the plan like
spark and the magnet were actually all
informed totally by building something
that's going to put net electricity on
the grid and the timing of that we still
hope is actually the early 2030s so
spark is the design of the takamakan arc
as the actual full intent thing it's
like a thing that actually puts the
energy on the grid so spark is named you
know intentionally that it's like it's
on for a short period period of time and
it doesn't have a it has yeah yeah you
know it's the spark of the fusion you
know Revolution or something like that I
guess we could call it um
yeah so those are those are so those are
sort of the programmatic challenges of
doing that and
um you know it's interesting you asked
about you talked about SpaceX so what
has evolved even in the last year or so
was in fact in March of 2022 the White
House announced that it was going to
start a program that kind of looks like
a SpaceX analogy that namely wow we've
got these things in the private sector
we should leverage the private sector
and the advantages of what they obtain
but also with the things like this is
going to be hard and it's going to cut
it's going to take quite a bit of
financing so why don't we set up a
program where we don't really get in the
way of the private sector Fusion
companies but we help them Finance these
difficult things which is how SpaceX
basically became successful through the
cots program fantastic right and that's
evolving as well too so like the fusion
ecosystem is almost unrecognizable from
where it was like five years ago around
those things how important is it for the
heads of the companies that are working
on nuclear fusion to have a Twitter
account and to be quite you said you
don't use Twitter I don't use that much
I mean there there is some element to
and I don't think this should be
discounted whatever you think about uh
figures like Jeff Bezos uh with blue
origin or Elon Musk or SpaceX
there is
a science communication yeah to put it
uh in nice terms that's kind of required
to really educate the public and get
everybody excited and sell the sexiness
of it I mean just even the videos of
SpaceX just being able to kind of get
everybody excited about going out to
space once again I mean there's all
kinds of different ways of doing that
but part I mean I guess most of the
companies do well you know is is to
advertise themselves to really sell
themselves it is yeah well actually it's
like I feel like one of the reasons on
this podcast and so like I I don't have
an official role in the company and one
of the reasons for for this was also
that it's interesting because when you
come from like you're running a company
it's it makes sense they're promoting
their own product and their own Vision
which totally makes sense but there's
also a very important role for academics
who have knowledge about what's going on
but are sufficiently distant from it
that they're not fully only so
self-motivated just by their own you
know you know projects or so forth and
for me this is I mean we we see
particularly the problems of the
distrust in technology
um and then honestly in the scientific
Community as well too it will be that
one of the greatest tragedies I would
say that if we go through all of this
and almost pull off what looks like a
miracle like Technologic and scientific
wise which is to make a fusion power
plant and then nobody wants to use it
because they feel that they don't trust
the people who are doing it or the
technology so we have to get so far out
ahead of this like so I give lots of
public lectures or things like this of
of accessing a larger range of people
we're not trying to hide anything you
can come and see you know come do tours
of our laboratory in fact I want to set
those up virtually as well too you might
look at our plasma size infusion center
YouTube channel so we are reaching out
through those meetings and it's really
important that we do those things but
it's also but also then realizing
setting up the realistic expectations of
what we need to do you know we're not
there like we don't have commercial
Fusion devices yet and you ask like what
are the challenges
I'm not going to get in into any deep
technical you know questions about what
the challenges are but it is it the
pathway not just to make fusion work
technically but to make it economically
competitive and viable so it is actually
used out in the private sector is a
non-trivial task and it's because of the
newness of it like we're simultaneously
trying to evolve the technology and make
it economically viable at the same time
those are two difficult couple tasks so
my own my own research and my own drive
right now is at Fantastic Commonwealth
Fusion systems is set up we have a
commercialization unit of that
particular kind which is going to drive
forward a token back in fact I was just
there there's discussions there's
there's dialogues going on around the
world with other kinds of ones like
Stellar Raiders which prefer different
kinds of challenges and economic
advantages but what we have to I know
what we have to have what we have to to
have is a new generation of integrated
scientists technologists and Engineers
that understand like how what needs to
get done to get all the way to the goal
line because we don't we don't have them
now like a multi-disciplinary yeah
exactly what's required I mean you're
talking about uh you said that Fusion is
quote the most
multi-disciplinary field you can imagine
yes yeah why why is that what are the
yeah well because because most of our
discussion that we've had so far is
really like a physics discussion really
so which don't don't
neglect physics is at the for origin of
this but I've already we touched on
plasma physics and nuclear physics which
are basically two you know somewhat
overlap and independent disciplines then
when it comes to the engineering it's
almost everything so so why is this well
let's build let's build an electromagnet
together okay what is this going to take
it's going to take
um it's basically electrical engineering
computer and so you under understand
what how it goes together and what it
happens computational engineering to
model this very complex integrated thing
materials engineering because it's this
you're pushing materials to their limit
with respect to stress and so forth
takes cryogenic engineering which is
sort of a sub-discipline but cooling
things to extremely low temperatures
probably some kind of chemistry thing in
there too well actually yeah which tends
to show up in the materials and that's
just one of the sub components of it
like almost everything gets hit in this
right so you're and you're also in a
very integrated environment because in
the end all of these things while you
isolate them from each other in a
physics sense in an engineering sense
they all have to work like seamlessly
together so it's one of those
um I mean I've in my own career I've
basically done Atomic physics
spectroscopy you know plasma physics uh
iron etching
um
so this includes Material Science
um uh something called mhd even
magnetohydrodynamics and now all the way
through like I I'm not even sure how
many different careers I've had it's
also by the way this is also an um a
recruiting stage for like young
scientists thinking to come in like my
comment to sign is if you're bored
infusion you're not paying attention
because there's always something
interesting to go and and do so that's a
really important uh part of what we're
what we're doing which isn't new in
Fusion actually and in fact is in the
roots of of what we've done at MIT but
holy cow like the proximity
of of possibility of commercial Fusion
is the new thing you know so my
catchphrase is like you might be
wondering like why aren't we doing all
these things like why weren't we pushing
towards economic fusion and new
materials and new methods of heat
extraction and so forth because
everybody knew Fusion was 40 years away
and now it's four years away there is a
history like you said 40 30 whatever
that kind of old joke uh there's a
history of fusion projects
that you know are characterized by cost
overruns and delays yeah
um how do you avoid this how do you
minimize the chance of this you have to
build great teams
um uh is one of them it tends to be that
the smaller the there's sort of a like
I'm not an expert in this but I've seen
this enough integrated certain equations
yeah well there's almost there's there's
I've seen this from enough teams like
I've seen also the futility of Lone
Geniuses trying to solve everything by
themselves yeah no but also
organizations that have 10 000 people in
them is is just not doesn't lend itself
at all to Innovation so like one of our
original sponsors and a good friend
vinod Coast I don't know if you've ever
talked to vinod Coastal he's a venture
guy he's got fantastic ideas about like
the right sizes of teams and things that
really innovate right and and there is
an Optimum place in there is that you
get enough cross-discipline and ideas
but it doesn't become so overly
bureaucratic that you can't execute on
it so so one of the ways and this was
one of the challenges of fusion is that
everything was leading towards like I
have to have like ex enormously large
like teams just to execute because of
the scale of the project the fact that
now through technology through both
technology and are you financing
Innovation we're driving to the point
where it's smaller focused teams about
doing those things so that's one way to
make it faster the other way to make it
faster is modularize the problem or
parse the problem so this is the other
difficulty infusion is that it you know
you tend to look at this it's like oh
it's it's really just about making the
plasma into this state you know here
that you get this energy gain no because
in the end if you can parse out the
different problems of making that and
then make it as separate as possible
from extracting the energy and then
converting it into electricity the more
separate those are the better they are
because you get parallel pass that
basically mitigate risk this is not new
infusion by the way and this is the way
that we attack most complex technology
logical you know integrated
technological challenges have you uh by
any chance uh seen some of the
application of artificial intelligence
reinforcement learning a deep mind has a
nice paper has a nice effort
um on basically using reinforcement
learning for learn control algorithm for
for controlling nuclear fusion yeah
um do you find those kinds of I guess
you throw them under the umbrella of
computational modeling do you find those
interesting promising directions they're
all they're all interesting so when
people you know I'll pull back maybe a a
natural question is like why is it
different in Fusion like there's a long
history diffusion right it was going on
for like I told you like stories from
the late 1960s like what's different now
right so I I think from the from the
technology point of view there's two
massive things which are different so
one of them you know I'll be parochial
it's the Advent of this new
superconducting materials because the
most mature ways that we understand
about how we're gonna get the fusion
power plants or magnetic fusion and by
the fact that you've got access to
something which like changes the
economic equation by an over and Order
magnitude is just a totally you know and
that that wasn't that long ago it was
only September of 2021 we actually
demonstrated the technology that changes
the the prospects there and the other
one is Computing and it's across the
whole Spectrum it's not just in control
of the fusion device it's actually in
the we actually use machine learning and
things like this in the design of the
magnet itself it's an incredibly complex
design space so you use those tools uh
the simulation of the plasma itself is
actually we're at a totally different
place than we were because of those
things so those are the two big drivers
that I see Ashley that make it different
uh and actually and it's interesting
both those things self enforce about
what you asked about before like how do
you avoid delays and things well it's by
having smaller teams that can actually
execute on those but now you can do this
because
the new magnets make the devices all
smaller and the Computing means your
human Effectiveness about exploring the
optimization space is way better it's
like they're all interlinked to each
other plus the modularization like you
said everything just kind of works
together to make smaller teams more
effective move faster and it's actually
and it's through that learned experience
I mean you know of the things that I'm
the most proud of about what came out in
fact the origins of thinking about how
we would use the the the the high
temperature superconducting magnets came
out of my design class at MIT and in the
design class like one of the features
that I kept I mean it was interesting I
actually learned I really learned along
with the students about this but like
this insistence on the features like we
can't have so many coupled integrated
hard technology developments like we
have to separate these somehow so we
worked and worked and worked at this and
in fact that that's what really in in my
opinion the greatest advantage of the
arc design and when it com you know and
and built into the common will Fusion
system idea is like to parse out the
problems like how can we attack these in
parallel
um yeah and so it really comes to a we
talked about philosophy it's like a
design philosophy like how do you attack
these these kinds of problems and you
know you do it like that and also like
you mentioned Offline that there's a
power to
you know as part of a class
yeah to decide a nuclear fusion uh well
it's
a reality and it's it's hard to imagine
a more powerful force than like 15 MIT
PhD students like working together
towards solving a problem and what I
always in fact we just we recently just
taught the the most recent you know I
say I teach it I mean I I guide it
actually the most recent version of this
where they actually designed you know
based on this National academies report
they actually designed like the pilot
plant that has bases and similarities to
what we had done before but you know I
kept wanting to like push the envelope
and where they are it's like the
creativity and the uh and the the energy
that they bring to these things is kind
of like it keeps me going like us you
know I'm not gonna retire anytime soon
when I keep seeing that kind of
dedication and it's wonderful around on
that um it almost not to overuse a um uh
uh or to paraphrase something right
which is that you know the the famous
um uh quote by Margaret Mead you know
never doubt that a small group of
dedicated you know persons will change
the world indeed it's the only thing
that ever has I mean that's just such a
powerful and inspiring thing for an
individual find the right team be part
of that and then you yourself your
passion your efforts could actually make
a big change yeah a big impact